hello and welcome to a little show
called ask ij
[Music]
hey guys what's up welcome to ask ij
this is another fantastic episode and i
decided this week that i'm gonna take
some google plus questions and some
questions from tumblr so i hope you guys
enjoy
let's go twitter questions who's your
favorite youtube musician currently i've
been obsessed with alex goose
[Music]
if nobody's bothered to ask yet how are
you doing well thank you for asking and
i'm doing quite fantastic how are you
can i smell the next apple product
before anyone else
nope i can't mario or luigi mario
can i think with portals if you've ever
actually watched me play portal you
obviously know that i can't do that why
are you doing this to me
i hate you hate you i hate you i just
portal over here
oh guess what i'm freaking portaling
back and forth my favorite shark is the
ron shark all right just keep eating it
oh that's really good cotton candy
that's yummy
jen wants me to post a screen cap of my
editing i had it in final cut pro and
here is a screenshot from this episode
please put me in your ask aj episode
comments and now for the part of the
show where i put your comments right
here if you want to be here leave a
comment below saying justine put me in
the next episode
tumblr questions
why did i make a tumblr well i've
actually been on tumblr since around
2007 but i just recently started using
it so i thought hey that'd be a great
place to take some new ask ij questions
so here we go who was i most excited to
see at the teen choice awards i don't
really know i didn't really go into it
thinking oh i'm so excited to see insert
name here but overall i enjoyed the show
at a good time
[Music]
i also really enjoyed the after party
because they had a lot of candy
did you guys see this there is so much
candy here team choice of exact party
matthew said he saw me on e-news the
other day
and you can find me there almost every
other friday reviewing dare i say viral
videos hate the word viral videos but i
can't think of what else to call them
viral videos
[Music]
videos
what do i think i'll be doing in five
years i have no
idea dear justine i really like this
girl how should i ask her out well i
think what you should do is write will
you go out with me on a little tiny
piece of paper and hand it to her oh and
don't forget make sure you add yes or no
so she can just circle one easily yuda
you the best google plus questions
do i stalk anyone
no
why would you say that i would never do
that i would never do that because
stalking is wrong stalking is bad
stalking is not a good thing it's not
good you shouldn't do it
what's my favorite hawaiian island well
the last time i was in hawaii i went to
kauai and i absolutely loved
it what i consider a droid phone i would
if i didn't love my iphone so much the
longest video i've ever made i don't
know if it's the longest but i actually
posted 20 minutes of me and my sister
shopping in whole foods yeah i know 20
freaking minutes unedited should i get
the big roll
i probably should
oh there's so much toilet paper so heavy
when will i be in vampire diaries i
don't know hopefully soon because it's
one of my favorite shows and i would
kill to be a vampire
website questions don't forget about
checking out part two on my blog at
ijustine.com where you guys ask me
questions on my blog so i answer them on
my blog in part two of ask ij check it
out hope you guys enjoy don't forget to
subscribe and don't forget to check out
the rest of my youtube channels here i
will see you guys in the next episode of
whatever i happen to post here
that's it bye